foreign
[Music]
thank you
I have to say I'm not feeling it
[Applause]
hey Conan my name is Yola and I'm from
Bergen Norway it was really nice talking
to you let me know if you guys are over
here hey y'all come on out here holy
look you came all this way just for
me yes
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Conan it's Anna and I'm calling from
Bangkok Thailand I'm friends with Anna
she told me that you have some problems
she attacked me
oh my God this is Thai boxing
Thai street food is notoriously spicy
[Applause]
why did I come to Bangkok do you want to
fight me yeah
[Music]
my luggage is gone problem solved
I am on the famous floating Market how
much I must have this
ah no I didn't buy that
you can't buy that kind of propaganda
what's caught me up would you
great
yeah that's fine
[Music]